hey guys how's it going this is my
sister Jenna and today we are going to
spiralize some vegetables my friend Nick
here who is actually behind the camera
we went to dinner once and he ordered a
zucchini pesto pasta but the pasta was
zucchini not yet
right now we're not making anything
we're just going to spiralize a bunch of
things that I have in my refrigerator
you show idea will it spiral eyes what
am I spiral eyes you're in this arm
that's not nice are we building a
computer or a space station is there a
link in your description of course wow
look at this look at all the things that
we can do so different blades do
different things this is what we would
want for the spaghetti spaghetti wanna
be girly fries this says angel hair
second in Rome are you reading the
instructions I have not looked at them
at all body block damn this in here make
sure it's firm okay I'm making sure is
okay what ordered produce on Amazon and
I thought this was the zucchini that I
was getting but this is the zucchini
that I actually got it's very smooth I
want to make a zucchini pasta in my
future so one of the most important
things is you gotta cut off the sides
you should probably wash your vegetables
and fruit Oz first did you put the blade
on there isn't this a blade that is
that's just the slicer about your gosh
yourself oh oh okay give me that thing
let's let's go Mitchell Mitchell what is
this
that's a turnip ya know the parson it's
a parsnip I don't know do we need like a
bowl to catch our we do is something
happening and very having these results
so far okay so now it's getting tangle
on the little nub
[Music]
oh I don't like it at all
wait but it looked looks good turned out
nice nice nice results I just wish this
was like a little easier to get out of
here
all right next not curly fries did you
get a potato whatever that's like to be
smart
oh there's jamming in there you just jam
it whoa now I've never seen curly fries
so then see you're asking a lot for this
machine
oh this looks like your hair leave me
alone I'm beautiful so we're gonna try
to spiralize some cabbage here it is no
it's so big run wrong way okay yeah make
cabbage sticks the smells gross I just
want to say I think you're all worried
I think healthy eating is very important
I would probably put this in the trash I
would need this in like a salad they
always put nice little cabbages and
salads I want you to hand spiralize this
parsnip what cabbage what's the point
food has to be at least an inch and a
half in diameter so this isn't gonna
work that makes way more sense than what
I was trying to do this gross alien who
do it out of here it works this looks
way better than this one pepper
they pick them out so what would you do
with that I put it in the sound oh it
smells like a carrot this is like Pepsi
have you ever had a carrot yeah I don't
like carrots they're gross
so we're gonna just kind of fry up these
potatoes and see what happens you know
I've never seen potatoes look like
spaghetti i okay
so put it down we've only got a tiny
little small pan here why is this purple
is idiom don't touch the pan wait - hot
hot hot to touch
oh wow I can't believe I made something
well guys thank you so much for watching
this was the first episode maybe the
last episode oh oh well do you guys have
any recipes please tweet them to me
because I would love to see them and I
will experiment before I actually make
the video so I can make sure it tastes
good if you have any suggestions for
will its fire lies let us know leave
those in the comments below and we will
get it
[Music]